Nick says, one more question on my end. Do you still go into city niche combo that looks like
the lowest hanging fruit, but nobody's paying for ads at my stage? Yes, I will. If it's low
hanging fruit. Okay. If you don't have enough money where the bills are paid and some move on.
Okay. Where I'm at right now, it's like, if I see it, like, for example, I remember seeing,
I was doing research and I saw this window tinting, don't love the niche, but I had a feeling
that I would be able to sell it because it was local to where I'm at. And it's so low hanging
guys. It was like the stupidest thing ever. And I was like, I don't even know if I want to do this,
but it was so low hanging. I'm like, I have to do it. We put up a website. I did zero SEO. I'm
talking zero, not a backlink, not nothing. And the site ranked. Okay. So if I see those opportunities,
I'll build them because it literally sometimes can be 45, 60 days. Those suckers are ranking,
which by the way, in these last modules, we're going to be releasing, you guys are going to
learn those strategies. You can start implementing those so that you can get those sites ranked.
But where I'm at now, yes. But as far as like for you, I probably wouldn't recommend it until
you get to a certain level. Okay. Now those are, I'm talking, those, what I'm just to clarify,
I'm talking specifically about city niche combinations where I'm okay. If I let that
thing just rank and I don't touch it for six months or three months or two months,
if you're talking about, do you go into a city niche combination, but you need to pre-sell it
type of a thing? Probably not, dude. Probably not. Like if there's not people paying for ads,
there's just too many people willing to pay for ads for me to dick around to that kind of stuff.
Okay. So that's just my personal preference. Can you still sell people that aren't paying for ads?
Of course. Of course you can. Okay. Of course you can, but it's just, it's like, why, why,
why make it harder on ourselves than we have to?